I'm no video editor, so these kinds of
motion graphics in my videos seemed
completely impossible for me. But I'm
going to show you today how you can
recreate these in just seconds using AI
and personalize them to your content
using a tool called Remotion. So, let's
dive in. Of course, even as a non-motion
graphic designer, you could use
templates and insert them into your
videos, but I always found that those
didn't quite match the vibe of my video,
didn't quite match my branding, and
weren't easy to personalize with my
content. Here's just a few examples of
graphic designs that I made using
Remotion. Here's a ven diagram that you
can insert your own content into. Here's
one where I drew inspiration from a
static graph and turned it into an
animation. And this one I actually took
inspiration from Ali Abdal's video and
recreated it. All right, let's go ahead
and install Remotion on your machine. I
will assume that you've already
installed cloud code which you'll need
to be using Remotion and kind of
prompting your motion graphics with.
Step one is to go to reotion.dev/doccks
and you'll end up on this page. We're
going to copy this and we're going to
open our terminal and we're going to
copy paste this in. So now it's going to
ask us how we'd like to start our first
project and we're just going to go with
blank. You can switch between these
using your up and down arrow keys. Let's
go ahead with blank. And then we're just
going to enter every time we accept
something. Yes, we want to add Tailwind
CSS. That's what they use to do the
emotion graphics with. And then yes. And
add agent skills to Claude. Right. So we
want Remotion as a skill. So every time
I'm just pressing enter as a key here.
All right. It's asking us which agents
to install. And we're just going to go
with the recommended. So enter.
Installation scope project sim link.
Just accept whatever they're saying
here. proceed with installation. Done.
Install the fine skills. So this is how
you can actually call the remotion skill
in cloud code. We're going to go with
yes.
Perfect. So here you have some commands
to call the skill with to start creating
your motion graphics. So here we have
the name of the project which is going
to be in your home directory. As you can
see here, it's called my video. to look
into this file. You can actually go cd
as a command in my video. So just open
that folder and then uh you can run
remotion. So let's open a new tab here
and we're just going to go
claude.
Yes, I trust this folder. So before we
start, just navigate to my video which
is the correct f folder.
Yes. And now npm rundev.
And that's basically going to open up
remotion in Chrome. So we can actually
view whatever motion graphic we're
making or creating.
Over here we can see that that command
opened up remotion for us. And this is
actually where we're going to see every
motion graphic that we prompt just be
created as a new composition as they're
called. So on the left here we have our
compositions. This one doesn't have a
name yet. We can rename it. But whenever
we start making them, they'll just
automatically be added there in
Remotion. Um, and you can actually view
what's being done here, as well as
render them in the end. But we'll go
over that. Now that we've set up
Remotion on our machine, we can actually
start grabbing inspiration for motion
graphics that we'd like to recreate in
Remotion. So you can think of any graph,
any title page, any diagram that you'd
like to recreate. I will preface this by
saying that some things work better in
reotion than others. So try to keep it
simple initially um and not too
complicated. Things like arrows are kind
of hard to recreate. But I'm going to
show you how I created the four videos
that I showed you at the start of this
video. And we're just going to recreate
them together. I'll show you exactly
where I find inspiration for motion
graphics. So you can actually start
building your own inspiration folder as
well. The first place I go to for
inspiration for motion graphics or
diagrams that I'd like to animate using
remotion is Pinterest. Now you might
think that most things on there are
static and that is true, but that's
okay. We can actually animate a static
image and that's kind of the power of
using Claude and Remotion to create
animations like this. So, this one
actually happens to be a GIF, but we can
actually feed that to Claude and it can
use it as inspiration to recreate this
as a motion design. I don't want the
Polish currency in my graph, but I want
to make a graph about my newsletter
subscription growth. So, we're just
going to go ahead and save this image as
something. So, let's say graph. And I
actually have in my home directory a
folder called animation examples which
we're going to save this to.
So we've saved that to graph. Now we're
going to head back to our terminal and
we're going to ask claude to recreate
this using remotion. I'm just going to
copy this
command C and then command V. And then
I'm going to tell it to use this as
information inspiration to create a new
composition.
It's going to ask us if we want to
proceed and we're going to say yes.
Now, in the background, we can actually
see when we go back to Chrome to our dev
environment, it created this animation.
So, let's play it and see how good of a
job it did.
Nice. So, that's super close to the
image that we fed it, right? Of course,
as I mentioned, I want this to be about
my subscription or my newsletter
subscription rate going up. So, we can
actually just prompt that using super
literal terms to make amendments here.
I'm going to say make this an upward
graph showing
newsletter
subscription subscriber growth to 12,500
subscribers.
It's so cool to see how it actually
comes up with the code for these graphs
and the actual motion design. So, you
have some context there. Let's see what
it came up with here.
Nice. So much for our first recreation
of the videos I showed you initially.
Let's do another one. Now, let's head
back to Pinterest and do another one
from my inspo folder. Personally, I
really like this one and I've already
saved it to my inspo folder. So, I'm
just going to drop that into cloud and
ask it to turn it into a motion graphic.
So, here's my example.
And here you can see by just drag and
dropping it the images here.
I'm just telling it to change the labels
of the bar because they're just an
example. I'm going to say change the
labels of the bars to Q1 to Q4 and
change the graph title to I don't know
marketing performance
2025 just to switch it up. Cool. So
Claude has been cooking and we're going
to see how well of a job it did with
this one. Here we go. Let's play this
one.
That's so cool. I'll be very honest,
I've tried this one a few times and
every time the result is different. So
that's really cool to see. Something
that's good to know is that you can also
feed this your own data. So let's say
you have an Excel spreadsheet with some
with some data that you could turn into
graphs. You can just upload that to
Claude and make the motion graphic super
realistic just increasing and following
your own data. Before I show you how I
draw inspiration from YouTube, let's do
one more drawing inspiration from
Pinterest. And we're going to be looking
at this ven diagram. I think ven
diagrams are so cool, but whenever you
use a template, I can't get them to be
personal to my content. So, I've already
saved this to my inspiration folder. As
always, we're going to go ahead and open
Claude again,
grab this from my folder, and again,
drag and drop. So, this is called image
two because it's the second image in our
chat. And we're going to say, animate
this ven diagram.
I find that the best thing to do is just
to give it an image and see what Claude
comes up with first because the more
information you give it initially, the
further away or the more room for
interpretation there is for Claude. So,
let's see how good of a job it does for
now. And then we can always change the
text, the font, or even the layout of
the video and make it horizontal. Let's
go open this in Remotion and see how
well it did.
Okay. So, there's room for improvement
here, but we can see that it did a
pretty good job. So, here you just have
to prompt the font to be smaller. Um,
and maybe we could even make this
horizontal. So, we can say make the
diagram horizontal
and make sure center font isn't
yellow.
intersection.
These singing verbs in Claude actually
send me every time and I can't wait to
turn them off.
Flipp
fling.
That's nauseiating. Cool. So, my bestie
said that we're done. So, let's go ahead
and see what it came up with here.
Awesome.
This is exactly what I wanted and it did
it in two tries. So, we can see that the
fonts on the sides are a bit off, but
you can basically go in um to a little
bit of this CSS here and just check like
what the height should be. Uh move it
lower or you can just describe that in
literal terms. Now I'd like to show you
the second way I find inspiration for
motion animations and that is while
watching videos. So the way this
workflow works is with one additional
step which is just that we can't upload
video directly to clots. So we just need
to analyze it frame per frame. So the
options you have here are let's say you
saw this Ali Abdal video and you like
the motion graphic that's coming up. You
can use TA to record your screen and
just save that video for reference. Or
you can use a tool like uh QuickTime or
Clean Shot to do that as well. I'm using
Tela, so I'm just going to show you in
quick shot. Uh Clean Shot, sorry.
And I'm just going to save that to my
inspiration folder as always.
Just going to rename that
Okay, so I've already mentioned that we
can't just drop videos into Claude code
directly. So we're just going to use a
tool called ffmpeg to analyze each frame
of the video that we've provided and ask
Claude to create a similar animation. So
here I'm going to tell it where to find
my inspiration file. Use ffmpeg
to analyze
in animation inspiration
folder
here and let's see
animation
where words come in one by one.
Okay, so terminal is asking me if it can
if it can access uh folders. Yes, it
needs to access it. It's asking me to
get some video data. That's fine. So now
it got the description of the video. You
can see here cream background with
decorative wavy shapes, icon at the top,
rounded square, and then the words that
were in the original animation. So that
did a good job. And now it's creating a
similar composition. Cool. Let's see how
well of a job it did by going over here.
And we're just going to play this.
I think that did really well. If we go
back to our original inspo pick,
inspo video, we can see that it's
somehow interpreted
red for the ages. But if anything, it
looks even better. It kept the same
colors and the same style. And then the
only thing that it didn't do very well
is to have a wavy uh background. But you
can always prompt that um and add that
there. Okay, so we're at the end of our
demo and I just want to show you how you
can use any of these animations in Tela
using the upload clip feature. You can
do this for any other um video tool as
well. Now, once we're done and we're
ready to use this, we're going to go
ahead and render this. And we select the
quality here. All right, let's go ahead
with the highest quality ProRes. And
let's call this
top.
Cool. Let's open this. And here we can
see that we have our title page ready to
use in our videos. Okay. So now this
video is actually ready to be used in
Tela. We're going to head over to Tela.
We're going to go add clip, use web app,
and we're going to go upload. And we're
going to drag and drop this file in
there. For now, in Tala, this works best
for title pages. So, let's say you
wanted to switch between sections or
chapters in your video. You can actually
use a motion animated title page. So,
this is what this would look like as a
title page.
And then it would just go into the rest
of your video. I know I'll be using this
to jazz up my videos. If you want more
tips on how to make your videos stand
out, whether it's in Tela or not, be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
cuz we'll be sharing more videos very
soon. And I can't wait to be using this
to level up my presentations and level
up my